[Music]
so uh
a hopeful bachelor receives over a
hundred applications after plastering
himself on billboards across the country
in the uk
let me show you the photo just for quick
context you sound sexy you better be
sexy dude hell yeah save me from an
arranged marriage
damn
over a hundred applications came in
there you go that's
malika wife.com find malik a wife you've
got to be pretty bald enough for all
those buildings
that's very true how many billboards
just go ahead make yourself you can get
a billboard pretty cheap i have to say
really you can hack them down yeah what
about nowadays
oh yeah especially now it's gonna be
it's gotta depend on the reason yeah why
did he go facebook ads instead
well this is definitely way more
powerful i gotta say he had a hundred
applicants over a hundred
so billboard's like what 1500 bucks
i don't i don't know i really think it
depends on where you're at and what they
do is like with stupid side fact but
let's say a person pays for like 20 days
for the month they'll like broker the
remaining days like way cheaper for like
people that you want their [ __ ] up like
slightly
is it like a sublease on a [ __ ]
billboard yeah yeah so we used to get we
used to get billboards done for like uh
records that were coming out and then uh
what we do is rather than just buy a
billboard you get one that someone uh
got most of the month and you'll just
like some guys always monthly people do
it all the time they'll like lease it
for the month and they'll sublease parts
of the days wow
and it's that
cost effective to get a whole new ad up
there yes it is yeah
interesting all right there it is um new
market yeah it was like 1500 i think wow
so we've got our one bachelor who's
received over 100 applications from
hopeful bachelorettes in a desperate bid
to save him from an arranged marriage
were there other like
indian chicks that were like in arranged
marriages and then they're like oh this
guy seems cooler
yeah the other chick from that
arrangement is made her own billboard
it says what about me.com what about
me.com
so muhammad malik can be seen lying
across huge billboards in both london
and birmingham with a cheeky grin on his
face directing suitors to his website
finding
malikawife.com
in a video on his page he says hi i'm
malik you may have seen my face on a
billboard somewhere i'm 29 live in la
vita london i'm an entrepreneur and a
foodie and i'm religious i'm looking for
someone who's working on herding which
is arabic meaning religion
i'm open to any ethnicity but come from
a loud punjabi family so the banter has
to be 100. if you're interested fill out
the form and check out my details see
uh pakistani
because he's
talked about arabic and stuff
he definitely used the word punjabi
so
i don't know my indians there's punjabi
muslims i'm assuming he was muslim he
saw my arabic um i'm not exactly sure
anybody know you know you have that
smart guy he's in there i think the hat
the punjab is the no no no because
that's a i think that's a muslim hat
usually punjab is
uh punjabis they they wear the what's
called like a head wrap yeah so that i
think that's synonymous with punjabi
males there it is that's why
isn't that sick but he's talking about
oh is it it's all about arabic stuff we
don't need sure yeah
i'm talking about buddies
we need to rash here because uh we don't
know we're gonna steal that we're gonna
go into this story
explaining his reasons beyond such
drastic measures he has pokemon
evolution teresh
okay so so his reasons behind such
drastic measures to find mrs right
mohammed explained i just haven't found
the right girl yet it's tough out there
i had to get a i had to get a billboard
to get seen
my ideal partner would be a muslim woman
in her 20s see muslim who's striving to
better her dean we don't need tesha i'll
[ __ ] tell tech what
jarrell
he added i'm an only child and look
after my mom and dad if this is a deal
breaker i don't think it'll work out
mama's profile describes him as a 29
year old muslim guy living in london
noting he is slim and five feet eight
inches tall
they use our measurements oh
oh yeah that's what you got he converted
it right now though can i hate on this
guy really it's my horse
if you're trying to get out of an
arranged marriage and you're doing
something like this this is just a
different more elaborate arrangement
maybe he wanted to open his options for
more arrangements
he's arranging another marriage because
maybe like he doesn't like the one that
his parents pick and he goes exactly and
maybe he gets to see this arrangement or
the other one he might not be able to
see the arrangement until wedding day
well i mean he's getting full on
applications so i mean he gets a he gets
to actually have choices that's all
different so that's already not a range
that's already optional well it depends
because i had a friend who um was doing
a um i used to improv this guy and he
was single and he was trying to get with
chicks so he did this thing called he
filmed like an infomercial called tim
wow and he and he did a similar thing
like a campaign to like date him and
he's like hey you know come to my
website and you're like you can print
out this coupon it's good for one date
with me mays kind of picture yeah like a
billy mays thing yeah and then uh i was
like
i was like oh this is great um so then i
i submitted um
to him
as a big girl yeah he's a fake girl i
wrote this i wrote this entire
i wrote like a [ __ ]
like four paragraph like page like page
and a half
about how i was from like virginia and
like uh you know i go to george mason
university out there and like i'm really
into literature and art and like
i've been looking for someone like you
and like i hope that you know we can hit
it off and stuff and i was like and i
just kept on going right talking about
my family and i have a i like dogs but
i'm not sure if i want one yet and then
i take a a detail and i got attached to
my picture and i pulled a picture of a
craigslist of a guy with a [ __ ] gut
out and he had a boner like
oh my god
a gun
and i was like yeah just let me know you
know like let me know what you thinking
and then now about a month later i saw
him because we do improv every month and
i was like
hey dude how's how's tim what going on
like you're getting interesting uh
did you did you keep a straight face i
did i did but um
he was like i took everything i had
every straight face king man
everything i have but but he um i never
even told him this to this day
he doesn't even
so many confessions on camera here
he um he was like
yeah actually yeah i got this thing from
this girl and i was like this seems cool
and then i clicked on his some guy's
dick
and that was like that's [ __ ] crazy
man i like laughed and i was like oh
that's [ __ ] funny i guess but that's
crazy
yeah yeah actually yeah i did yeah so i
know the whole thing backfired what did
he [ __ ] beat it yeah he didn't think
he was gonna get some of those action he
got what if no girl's message and that
was the only [ __ ]
god
and that was in the top of his mind so
that's probably what it was he probably
didn't get that many like
responses and he really likes yours and
then right at the end was the picture
you guys remember early youtube where
people would upload these like dating
[ __ ] video
what do you call them where they're just
like yeah like this i like long video
dating service stuff yeah
yeah yeah there's a bug that i just went
down the rabbit hole of you mean like
the vhs found tapes from the 80s of
those ones the submitted ones and they
would upload them on youtube no like
dudes who are searching for chicks yeah
oh they just straight up make them for
youtube yeah no no no so like so like
let's say they had this video dating
service back in the 80s or 90s right
some dude would get that they would find
it because they worked there and then
they would be uploading this [ __ ] on
youtube and it was one guy
is that not it no it's not this is still
this is still pg-13 so we can still
upload this that guy gets all the [ __ ]
just wanted to bring a reference visual
for nick because i know that he was
thinking about it yeah and that's
exactly what i was picturing
there was one guy that would just be
freaking out and he goes you gotta
[ __ ] rummage through a [ __ ] trash
can for a playboy and jack off
do you guys remember that one yeah he
gets he loses his [ __ ] right it's
because he's like i like long walks
and i just need a woman because i'm so
tired of going rummaging into a dumpster
for a playboy
yeah look that one up he's got denim
jacket yeah if you put vhs dating tape
it will be the first or second one it's
[ __ ] good it is classic you guys
never saw this [ __ ] this was so popular
you guys know who geislain is right poo
the star wars kid
that was an attempt at getting a date as
well
oh when he's in the garage yeah
oh that guy that's he's trying to get a
date he's trying to show off her chicks
yeah that dude crushing harder than him
over there 100
i mean he had over a thousand people
reaching out i would just say it's the
wrong era because right now he would
probably be getting all the twitch girls
crushing
crushing star wars kid bad timing yeah
that's it stephen moore this guy it's
also how it's crazy how some guys how
off they are on what they think chicks
want yeah
like he's so frustrated
i know i know he's like chicks want this
here's joe's guy you gotta watch this
dude he's my he was one of my favorite
old school youtube videos
that
went viral just have a seat there
sit right there
oh [ __ ] i think i do he looks like a
good looking guy too
he's angry though yeah that's two he's
too bad
[Music]
looks like a skinny johnson
is steven morris
and um
never done this one before um
i'm 26 years old i work down at the
fourth realm it's a bookstore it's a
complex store and uh i'm single
and i'm just looking for somebody who
likes to have i'm just looking for
somebody who likes to have fun and is a
fun loving type gal uh brunettes or
something and they're so redheads are
blond for something uh
tall women or shorts because height is
in the eye of the beholder
but someone who likes me for me
is who i'm looking for because i'm i'm
that type of guy who likes me
when you
and we could go out and do all kinds of
things
all kinds of music what i really want is
someone who'll call me and will love me
because i'm everyone i know is married
and i'm i don't know anybody or anything
and it's just not right when
because i deserve love like anybody else
i don't need to rummage through that
dumpster for a playboy god give me a
but there's but there's real ones that
are like montage one's a real bunch man
but for playboy yeah
if i didn't fall back i think he would
have sold this yeah i think he could
have gotten away with it it was pretty
good like very heightened all the way
which is
[Laughter]
i just want someone who likes me for me
not like all my cool connections and
[ __ ]
you